et en forme et pourtant et pourtant les
siens elle a pris dans la gueule cet
après midi et oui on va pas se mentir
kelly vous avez passé une après-midi
alors je tout vous raconter gentiment
gedia kelly voilà on va faire une
parodie ensemble ils étaient hyper
contente de faire un truc avec vous
calmez vous quand même on est en
clientèle mais c'est moi je lui dis à
viña lyon n'étant clientèle on se calme
de vider la salle comme s'ils croyaient
j'ai été déçu je lui ai dit on va faire
bradley cooper et lady gaga est un
bateau on va tourner un truc huawei
s'est montrée à bradley cooper
non moi je suis bois devait couper
bradley circoncis quoi et donc kelly je
lui ai dit écoute mais toi en lady gaga
et attends moi mais je vous ai appelé
vous m'avez dit j'arrive dans cinq
minutes
ouais bien sûr oui années suivant soit
en train de mogari lundi commençait sans
moi oui alors elle a commencé sur moi et
elle pensées tournées parodie de la
champions chalot c'est de la parodie
chevènement
[Musique]
ouais
cette parodie on va la faire voilà c'est
ça s'appelle cha cha cha malo si on
mange des chamallows même si l'état
arrive s'en fout voilà numérique loi
mais elle avait commencé à tourner et lé
ton lady gaga est malheureusement tout
ne s'est pas passé comme prévu
et ça va être l'objet d'une nouvelle
enquête à s es prix de la soupe de
poisson encore et oui elle pensait donc
faire une parodie de la chanson on va
avoir le son un moment l'émission ces
artistes ouverte
[Musique]
fermée hier tout écart de parler sinon
je vais venir en régie et vous irez au
bon moment il s'inquiétait pas dire au
bon moment en tout cas le maillot jaune
nous va très bien